de fait le point sur les projets en
cours victoire de niki lauda au grand
prix automobile de brands hatch en
grande-bretagne didier pironi second
prend la tête du championnat du monde
des conducteurs
et puis hinault imbattable il a encore
remporté l'étape contre-la-montre à
martic ses suivants tout à fait lâcher
au classement général et à monsieur
bonsoir plus de 200000 personnes hier
soir à tel aviv pour soutenir menahem
begin pour la première fois le premier
ministre israélien a lancé l'idée d'une
confédération avec la jordanie pour la
première fois également
il a fixé un délai précis pour le départ
des palestiniennes beyrouth moins d'un
mois at il dit démonstration de force
donc de la part de mendy guînes qui
entendait d'abord prouver qu'il avait
l'appui de la plus grande partie de ses
propres compatriotes dernier qui a volé
la vedette alors que sharon ministre de
la défense à qui les fait plus applaudi
que le premier ministre monsieur begins
c'est la question que se pose la presse
ukrainienne de ce matin deux cent mille
personnes s'étaient déplacées hier soir
à tel aviv pour applaudir et conforter
les deux hommes dans leurs actions
une manifestation organisée pour
démontrer à l'étranger et aussi à
l'opposition intérieure à la guerre que
le gouvernement bénéficie du soutien de
la majorité de la population et les
sondages sont toujours là pour le
prouver
mais ce soutien populaire est il
suffisant pour régler le problème de
beyrouth ouest
non à preuve l'humour dont a fait preuve
le ministre de la défense monsieur
sharon en déclarant si personne ne veut
de l'ol paie nous pouvons l'accueillir
en israël suivi de l'avertissement de
monsieur begin
nous n'attendrons pas encore trente
jours pour régler le problème
vous êtes autant de preuves blocage des
négociations sur l'évacuation des
combattants palestiniens
en attendant godot titre ce matin le
jerusalem post d'oiseaux et en
l'occurrence le ministre des affaires
étrangères syrien que monsieur reggane
doit rencontrer mardi pour essayer de le
convaincre d'accepter d'accueillir le
real
les syriens dont on dit que le nom
officiel est destiné à faire monter les
enchères pour obtenir le droit de rester
sur leurs positions dans la plaine
libanaise est aussi d'obtenir de
substantielles subsides de l'arabie
saoudite pour accueillir l'ol paie sur
son territoire mais en fait on peut
aussi penser que le président assad est
réellement inquiet de l'arrivée en syrie
de l'ol paie quand on sait mais
problèmes intérieurs qui sont déjà les
siens ont dit aussi en désespoir de
cause que provisoirement l'ol paie pour
s installer au nord du liban dans la
région de tripoli
une suggestion faite par des hommes
politiques y règne et qui n'a pas encore
été démentie par le gouvernement de
jérusalem ont dit enfin mais on dit tant
de choses comme par exemple que monsieur
kissinger pourrait reprendre du service
pour régler le problème de beyrouth
ouest après les soins des spécialistes
qu'on ferait en quelque sorte appel aux
magiciens c'est dire que le problème est
loin d'être réglé
menahem begin qui soit dit en passant a
lancé une mise en garde à l'ayatollah
khomeini si jamais vous envisagez une
marche vers jérusalem aux forces
seraient écrasés à mi-chemin aviv le
premier ministre israélien est proche au
mans revient tout juste du liban pour
préparer le dossier spécial que vous
présenterez demain soir dans ce journal
parlons d'abord de ce délai d'un mois
accordé aux palestiniens par les
israéliens c'est un petit pu reconnaître
un de délai en ville et la difficulté à
conclure
oui c'est vrai elle sur place on
constate que l'offensive israélienne
marque un temps d'arrêt les palestiniens
le met à profit pour se renforcer
militairement politiquement et puis
aussi tenté de se faire reconnaître sur
la scène internationale notamment par
les etats-unis alors quand les
israéliens disent que le temps travaille
pour les palestiniens là c'est vrai ils
ont raison mais pour l'instant israël ne
peut pas aller plus loin pour plusieurs
raisons il ya d'abord les pressions
américaines qui veulent encore donner du
temps à la mission de philippe abîme il
y a les pressions intérieures on a vu
les images de deux cent mille
manifestants pour béguines mais il ya
une semaine c'était cent mille
manifestants contre bed-in c'est tout de
même important
il ya aussi des morts supplémentaires
que représenterait une offensive sur
beyrouth ouest
il faut pas oublier que les israéliens
ont déjà perdu 300 soldats dans la
guerre du liban c'est beaucoup et puis
le fait aussi qu'il ya encore trois cent
mille libanais qui vivent à beyrouth
ouest en les israéliens avaient misé sur
le départ des libanais de beyrouth-ouest
s'il n'était resté que les palestiniens
il aurait pu plus facilement pénétrer
dans beyrouth ouest notamment faire
intervenir l'aviation là ils ne peuvent
tout de même pas fait remettre
intervenir l'aviation sur une vidéo où
il reste encore trois cent mille civils
qui vivent à beyrouth alors justement
parlé un petit peu dures conditions de
vie
malgré ce blocus qui semble un peu
poreux oui le blocus n'est pas
imperméable on a pu le constater à
plusieurs reprises avant de rentrer à
paris nous avions revisité avec roland
tourte le camp palestinien de morges et
le bras je n'ai qui est juste à côté des
villes israéliennes et vous le voyez dès
que les bombardements s'arrête
la vie reprend et la nourriture les
fruits les légumes parviennent à percer
le blocus israélien qui se relâchent
environ un jour sur 3 mais il faut dire
que les prix ont triplé et ses réfugiés
palestiniens doivent recevoir une aide
financière de l'ol paie pour acheter à
manger
le kilo de tomates est passé par exemple
à 20 livres c'est à dire 30 francs et
puis 20 francs pour une 12e 2 mais enfin
vous le voyez on mange encore à beyrouth
bien que ces marchands ne reste ici
qu'une heure ou deux par jour
en revanche les sens ne passe pas à
beyrouth ouest et le peu qui reste est
réquisitionné par les combattants
palestiniens
ce qui fait d'ailleurs la colère des
habitants de beyrouth ouest gars rendez
vous donc à philippe rochot avec roland
torse pour l'ensemble de votre reportage
qui fait une dizaine de minutes
demain soir tout à l'heure lagence
palestine oif a fait état d'une reprise
des tirs dans le sud de beyrouth malgré
le cessez-le-feu
et puis le chef de la gauche libanaise
walid joumblatt et toujours ce soir à
damas le ministre saoudien des affaires
étrangères et en lui à washington
deuxième conflit au proche-orient la
guerre iran irak téhéran a tout à
l'heure menacé de prendre des mesures
contre tous les états du golfe qui
fournirait l'irak en armes sur le
terrain est bien
les communiqués le plus contradictoire
selon qu'ils émanent bien sûr de l'une
ou l'autre partie
jean marc loos
quelque part sur le front reste voici
les héros que selon la télévision
irakienne ont vaillamment repousser
l'envahisseur iranien contre attaque qui
en 24 heures aurait coûté la vie à plus
de 3400 soldats de l'ayatollah
mais aujourd'hui l'irak cesse de faire
état du nettoyage je cite de son
territoire en clair bagdad reconnaît que
les combats continuent à l'est de
bassorah deuxième grande ville du pays
bombardé hier par l'artillerie iranienne
pour les experts militaires en poste
dans la région l'objectif de téhéran
n'est pas forcément de s'emparer de
bassorah l'armée iranienne pourrait
tenter de contourner la ville par
l'ouest et se contentait d'isoler le
grand port iranien du reste du pays
une première étape en sommes sur la
route de bagdad si l'on en croit les
proclamations des chefs militaires
iraniens au moment où téhéran fait
alterner propos rassurants a mises en
garde ces images répercutée par les
télévisions arabes ne contribue guère à
apaiser l'inquiétude de l'arabie
séoudite et de ses voisins du golfe
londres les suites de cette affaire
d'espionnage que nouveau réveil ou yeah
eh bien on s'oriente maintenant vers un
débat d'urgence aux communes sur la
sécurité nationale
mais l'on parle surtout ce soir dans la
capitale britannique de la fin de la
grève des chemins de fer dans quatre
heures maintenant les quelques 23 1000
conducteurs de train en grève depuis
deux semaines vont reprendre le travail
à l'appel de leur syndicat qui avait été
désavoué par l'ensemble du mouvement
syndical anglais les fameux trait
d'union un échec qui laissera bien sûr
des traces d'un arabe la fin quelque peu
dramatique de cette grève des chemins de
fer marque effectivement un échec
cuisant pour le mouvement syndical
britannique tout entier et cela pour
trois raisons d'abord cette grève
coûteuses et impopulaires n'aura en
définitive servi à rien et n'a sans
doute totalement paralysé le réseau
ferré britannique pendant quinze jours
pourtant ce soir les grévistes n'ont à
peu près rien obtenu et les horaires
flexibles qu'il refusait obstinément
devrait entrer en application dans les
jours qui viennent
deuxième motif d'inquiétude pour les
syndicats cette grève aura mis l'accent
sur leurs divisions dans une affaire
très vite transporté sur le plan
politique
malgré une leur détermination les 23000
conducteurs de train en grève
vous trouvez que peu d'échos dans les
autres syndicats leurs revendications
étant considérés il semble utile comme
un combat d'arrière-garde ses autres
syndicats ayant déjà accepté le principe
des horaires flexibles
enfin un dernier point à l'échec de
cette grève va certainement renforcer
malgré la douleur dans l'idée que la
manière forte paye dans ce genre de
situation
la menace brandie par la direction des
bruits d'israël de fermer l'ensemble du
réseau
cette menace semble en effet avoir été
décisive et les 225 mille cheminots
concernés par la fermeture n'ont pas
manqué de faire pression sur leurs
camarades pour les amener à reprendre le
travail
à tel point que le leader des grévistes
monsieur révoque tonnes estimé tout à
l'heure avec beaucoup d'amertume que
cela ressemblait beaucoup pas une
trahison
reste maintenant au mouvement syndical
britannique a tiré les conclusions de
cet échec qui intervient dans une
conjoncture particulièrement sombre on
devrait en effet connaître mardi le
nouveau chiffre du chômage en
grande-bretagne
un chiffre qui devrait dépasser les
trois millions deux cent mille chômeurs
autre sujet de conversation là bas les
tracas de la reine qui a passé la nuit à
l'hôpital pour se faire extraire une
dent de sagesse
c'est sa deuxième nuit blanche en une
semaine après la fameuse parenthèse de
l'intruse buckingham qui vient
d'apprendre voulait simple
m'entretenir la reine de ces problèmes
familiaux quatre enfants sa femme
l'avait quitté pas de salaire alors la
reine at il déclaré à part lui prêter
une oreille sympathique et a semblé
vraiment intéressés par ce que je lui
racontais elle m'a dit je suis moi même
une mère j'ai quatre enfants mon fils
aîné charles que vous connaissez bien à
peu près votre âge et il a conclu la
conversation en disant bien je suis
rentré ici trop facilement vous devriez
faire quelque chose pour votre sécurité
c'est vraiment diabolique ensuite
l'épisode des cigarettes et puis vous
savez tout alors on va reprendre un
petit peu notre sérieux pour vous parler
des déclarations de georges fillioud
aujourd'hui dans le journal du dimanche
sur l'éventualité assez sérieuse une
cinquième chaîne est qualifié de
commercial et pas de priver alors qu'est
ce que cela veut dire où en est on de
tous ces projets que vous allez
peut-être un petit peu de mal à suivre
on vous parlait le mois dernier encore
de quatrième chaîne patrick esther a
essayé d'être le plus simple possible
dans ses réponses
parmi les premières tâches commerciales
qui attendent ariane placé en orbite des
satellites de télévision directe des
satellites qui se trouve à trente six
mille kilomètres de la terre et qui
parce qu'il tourne à la même vitesse
qu'elle semble immobile
celle orbite géostationnaire une orbite
déjà tellement encombrées qu'il y a
quelques années à genève les places
disponibles ont été répartis entre les
différents pays
pourtant il faut savoir que les
émissions télé de ses satellites couvre
de larges zones du sol et bien sûr ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières nationales
à condition d'être équipé de ces
antennes ronde un belge un allemand ou
un espagnol pourront par exemple
recevoir des programmes français et les
français quasiment tous les programmes
européens
tout cela n'est pas de la science
fiction
c'est aujourd'hui que se distribuer les
places sur les satellites qui seront
lancés dès 1985 par ariane grâce à un
programme franco allemand ces deux pays
seront les premiers à disposer cette
date de deux satellites semblables tv
sat pour les allemands tdf 1 pour les
français
tf1 disposera de trois canaux de
télévision le premier pour tf1 le second
pour antenne 2 le troisième étant encore
disponibles actuellement
en effet fr3 ne peut pas utiliser ce
canal puisqu'il faire 3 est une chaîne à
vocation régionale
diffuser sa vingtaine de programmes
régionaux et faire 3 continuera à
utiliser le réseau d'émetteurs au sol
comme la quatrième chaîne d'ailleurs
dont on a beaucoup parlé il y à un mois
celle ci utilisera le vieux réseau
d'émetteurs de tf1 qui servait la
retransmission en noir et blanc 819
ligne cette quatrième chaîne pourrait
être consacrée aux films commerciaux
moyennant éventuellement une redevance
supplémentaire d'environ 150 francs par
mois
reste donc toujours ce troisième canal
de libre sur notre satellite
bien sûr celui ci pourrait être cédé un
groupe privé de presse ou à une
télévision étrangère comme radio télé
luxembourg
pourtant les déclarations de georges
fillioud laisse penser que cette fois on
s'oriente vers une véritable cinquième
sean dépendant de l'état par
l'intermédiaire d'une société d'économie
mixte avec capitaux privés une cinquième
chaîne entièrement financé par la
publicité au fond semblent penser
georges fillioud si une chaîne
supplémentaire doit arroser le
territoire national
tant qu'à faire qu'elles soient
françaises il n'est pas vraiment
nécessaire que le premier satellite
français de télévision directe soit
celui qui fasse voler en éclats le
monopole de l'état voilà répétons le il
ne s'agit que de projets tout ça n'est
pas encore complètement décidé c'est un
peu le projet également que cette
première attribution de fréquences aux
radios privées sur modulation de
fréquence à paris il n'y a que 17 places
et au moins dix fois plus de demandeurs
autrement dit personne n'est content et
il n'est même de grands absents choix
définitif mercredi prochain gérard inné
pour les radios libres c'est la grande
lessive et la déception sur 150 radios
locales à paris qui avait demandé une
attribution de fréquences
une vingtaine seulement pourrais tu
aimais qu il voulait conquérir 10
millions d'auditeurs
hélas la commission a tranché encore
qu'il y ait un examen de rattrapage
mercredi et jeudi prochains pour la
commission il y as foule sur la bande fm
et la qualité de l'écouté s'en ressent
d'où le tri et bien sûr la polémique
les deux fédérations de radios libres
dénonce le critère du choix
la commission n'aurait pas tenu compte
de l'ancienneté de certaines radios né
bien avant le dit m bonsoir vous êtes à
l'écouté de radio verte sur 99 mégahertz
comme tous les soirs et les 22h30 vous
entendez donc traduire vers une station
ni interdite ni autorisé ce soir sarwar
de rock français tout à fait particulier
si l'on peut s'attendre à un
élargissement de la part de la
commission hollow télédiffusion de
france demeure décidés à ce que 15
stations seulement puisse être entendu
sur paris reste la solution du
regroupement pour certaines radios
solution refusée par une partie d'entre
elles
car alors pourrait-on encore parler de
radios libres
voilà à mes côtés jean claude bessy ce
qui est l'avocat des radios libres non
fédérée à ce que vous trouvez que cette
formule de regroupement est une bonne
formule et à puisque vous me donnez
l'occasion de parler à vos
téléspectateurs j'aimerais quand même
souligner que le problème et les
mécontentements qu'on connaît en ce
moment sont limités à l'hypothèse de
paris pour tout le reste de la france a
bien fonctionné et je crois qu'on peut
rendre un hommage au président au look a
su conduire des travaux très très très
délicat alors osef paris en ce concerne
blary ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on a
adoptées pour parer une procédure très
particulière on a demandé à chaque
membre d'établir la liste de ses
préférences et cette procédure a été
critiquée l'abord faudrait expliquer
pourquoi on a choisi une procédure
différente de celle qu'on avait choisi
pour la province en province ont
rapporté dossier par dossier ont voté
dossier par dossier en débattent et
dossier par dossier pourquoi n'at-on pas
fait préparer bien pour deux raisons
qu'il faut connaître
d'une part en raison de l' hyper
encombrement la région parisienne elle
avait pour conséquence que si on devait
statuer dossier par dossier en
commission en séance officielle de
commissions ça aurait pris des centaines
de gens n'auraient pas pu statuer sur
les autorisations en temps utile ça
aurait reporté à six mois l'octroi des
autorisations définitives et la seconde
raison de ce choix de cette méthode faut
la connaître ses responsabilités je
pense pas que ce soit mauvais
responsabiliser chaque membre de la
commission en lui imposant danic et ses
préférences de la vie il ya des gens qui
restent sur le prêt alors pourquoi c'est
exclu certains comme rfm radio
libertaire ou à radio fréquence gaie
sont assez connus est ce que c'est il ya
du verglas pensées politiques ou
idéologiques
je crois encore une fois et pardon si je
ne réponds pas très directement à votre
question que il faut quand même
expliquer comment il est passé à cette
liste de synthèse en effet à la suite
d'une indiscrétion cette liste de
synthèse qui aurait pas dû publier l'a
été elle ne recopie pas peut-être
textuellement les préférences et nom de
la commission
mais effectivement elle tient compte de
la nécessité de donner une chance aux
radios historique est né sait également
de tient compte de ce qu'il s'est
produit de nombreux regroupements
depuis que les membres de la commission
ont indiqué leur préférence alors
évidemment il n'y a pas identité exacte
entre la liste de synthèse et le
hit-parade établi par les membres de la
commission
on s'est appuyé là dessus pour protester
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas que
il y est tu magouilles le mot est
inesthétique pourtant je peux pas être
taxé de complaisance à l'égard des
pouvoirs publics quand il s'agit de
radios libres
quels qu'ils soient ces pouvoirs publics
jeudi jamais été complaisant à leur
égard je crois pas qu'ils aient pu
magouilles on a respecté principalement
la volonté de chaque membre de la
commission en tempérant un petit peu
alors le choix les phénix télé c'est le
22 juillet terre mercredi prochain il y
aura à peu près à ce moment-là 17 radios
libres sur farhi est ce que vous croyez
alors là on parle de l'avenir à ce que
ces 17 stations vont vraiment pouvoir
survivre sans publicité alors là je pose
est très très bonne question car en
effet on ne peut pas accueillir tout le
monde et il y aura nécessairement des
mécontents ça c'est une certitude mais
je crois que quel que soit les radios
autorisées et quel que soit leur nombre
quel que soit leur nombre et le détail
de chacune d'entre elles l'entreprise de
libération des ondes ne peut qu'échouer
si on ne se préoccupe pas d'un aspect
essentiel c'est l'auto financement
indépendant des radios libres
je crois qu'il faut mettre en place
d'urgence d'une part la prévient de
ressources et de ressources qui
permettent une totale indépendance à
l'égard des pouvoirs publics
il faut s'en préoccuper car je trouve
paradoxal qu'on introduise à forte dose
la série la publicité sur le service
public et qu'on continue d'interdire aux
radios locales privées la démarche
inverse serait peut-être plus logique
quand on m'a effectivement sur ce
qu'elle disait donc georges fille du à
propos de la cinquième chaîne de
télévision la bataille de paris une
interview de gaston defferre à paraître
demain dans le matin
il y aura une commune une commune unique
cela est acquis a dit le ministre de
l'intérieur j'ai quant à moi est la
preuve de ma bonne foi
vous savez pour bien apprécier la
situation il faudra la considérer
lorsque tout sera terminé
jusqu'à maintenant dit le maire de
marseille cette situation un davantage
rapporté à jacques chirac
kanu mais en politique il ne faut jamais
se hâter de juger voilà pour la
politique
demain reprise des consultations
sociales là matignon avec en première
ligne les fonctionnaires avec daniel
leconte maintenant le commentaire des
deux catastrophes de la nuit une
collision ferroviaire en suisse et une
explosion dans un club de londres
ces chaps encore du bâtiment visé par
une explosion dans le quartier de soho à
l'ong à minuit hier une altercation
entre joueurs chinois dans une salle de
jeux clandestines dégénère deux inconnus
entre dans les sous-sols lançant
cocktails molotov et prennent la fuite
sept personnes sont tuées par une
première explosion suivie d'une autre
duo gaz quand les secours arrivent sur
les lieux
sow est un quartier chinois et scotland
yard retient l'hypothèse d'un règlement
de comptes entre bandes rivales
ces images spectaculaires ne viennent de
suisse des tôles des formes et des rails
tordu des vagues ont éclaté c'est ce
qu'il reste à othmarsingen après la
terrible collision qui s'est produite la
nuit dernière à trois heures de train
direct dortmund francfort et munich a
heurté de plein fouet un convoi de
marchandises qui remontaient d'italie
vers l'allemagne fédérale
les six wagons couchés sur le ballast
sous la violence du choc
la police helvétique retire à six morts
et une soixantaine de blessés
à l'heure actuelle on ne connaît
toujours pas les raisons de la
catastrophe
il faut savoir aussi qu'il ya eu la nuit
dernière de violents affrontements entre
des maghrébins et des jeunes campeurs
sur une plage de cannes
trois cents personnes ont participé à
cette bagarre généralisée deux jeunes
filles avaient été importunée par les
maghrébins le calme n'a été rétablie que
trois heures plus tard bagarre également
dans un restaurant d'ormesson dans le
val de marne une douzaine de clients
mécontents estimé que la viande servie
été trop dur alors non seulement ils ont
refusé de payer l'addition mais ils ont
en plus en porter la caisse avant de
s'enfuir en brandissant des armes les
sports maintenant avec tout d'abord bien
entendu là bien jolie performance de
bernard hinault dans le tour de france
il a gagné la 14e étape contre la montre
où la main et là maintenant cinq minutes
d'avancé plus sur ses poursuivants au
classement général battus à valence
d'agen par geri knetemann hinault a
retrouvé aujourd'hui sa suprématie en
contre la montre individuel malgré le
vent violent et la chaleur torride 45
minutes 12 secondes sur les 32
kilomètres et demi du parcours soit 43
km 136 de moyens il devance gagnent 20
nouvelles viennent de 48 secondes et job
zoetemelk de 53 cleitman lui n'a pas
confirmé son précédent succès y débattu
d'une minute 10 1 bernard hinault très
éprouvée à l'arrivée par la chaleur et
par l'enthousiasmé du public
là
autre tour de france à la voile ces
huit-là le bateau le havre l'a encore
emporté à perros-guirec aujourd'hui au
classement le havre est en tête toujours
devant marseille brest et dunkerque en
automobile victoire de niki lauda au
grand prix de grande-bretagne de formule
1 devant didier pironi qui prend la tête
du championnat du monde des conducteurs
décidément être en pole position au
départ d'un grand prix ce n'est pas
toujours confortable qui était grosse
perf ne réussit pas à démarrer au moment
du tour de chauffe il est passé par tous
les autres concurrents et malgré un
effort l'indiscutable pour venir se
placer il partira derrière tous les
autres pour lui la course est déjà
terminée
regardez bien le départ à droite pas
très il ne peut démarrer pironi lesdites
mes armes ou le percute avec sa roue
avant gauche
nous allons revoir ce départ au ralenti
un départ qui met out patrese et arnould
au premier quart de la course puisque
est abandonné le seul en tête
niki lauda le pilote autrichien ne sera
jamais inquiété et remporte facilement
son deuxième grand prix de la saison le
19e de sa longue et brillante carrière
hier nuit c'est une ferrari qui s'impose
celle de didier pironi pironi en profite
par la même occasion pour prendre la
tête du championnat du monde des
conducteurs puisque watson et rosberg ne
termine pas la course
un autre français patrick tambay mais
aussi sur ferrari prend la troisième
place et ce pour son deuxième grand prix
en formule 1 un beau tir groupé des
ferrari d'autant que didier pironi a
maintenant cinq voix l'avant sur watson
11 / niki lauda 14 sur os berne
enfin en 24 heures de planche à voile en
solitaire la baule c'est néerlandais van
der sar qui l'a emporté devant trois de
ses compatriotes pire c'est le prix
handicap d'été disputé cet après midi à
saint cloud a été remporté par ma dira
le 9 suivi de vieux carré las et de
premier concert le 6 février donc neuf
as 6 un tout p'tit tiercé dans l'ordre 3
185 francs et dans un ordre différent
donc toujours pour 5 francs
77 francs seulement de l'an terminer ce
journal en musique comme nous en avons
pris l'habitude depuis quelques jours ce
soir du jazz avec la grande parade de
nice qui va s'achever dans deux jours
aux arènes de cimiez la grande parade
c'est à dire le jazz en liberté
le jazz sans faux col nous disent louis
doucet et patrick voit nos envoyés
spéciaux
rice
trois podiums ouverts en même temps de
5h à minuit trois fois cette heure régal
21 concerts par jour soit 210 entre le
10 et le 20 juillet telle est mais là
messieurs la grande parade du jazz demi
à
oui
il est préférable que la marque
vous pouvez voir les amis de vingt mille
lieues des scènes françaises c'est un
rendez-vous de copains ne vous en rendez
vous l'ami oui oui oui
georges wind 250 musiciens si c'est une
histoire de fous non non non c'est pas
faux c'est c'est pour moi une histoire
d'amour c'est pour moi le jazz et ma vie
et c'est tout les musiciens sont mes
amis
les
moi
et
le tout
wouah oui oui oui oui
en
la météo maintenant alain gillot-pétré
en jaune comme bernard hinault oui mais
mais chez moi je fais pas le tour de
france rien de neuf sous le soleil
demain ce sera le même temps
qu'aujourd'hui prévu pour dans 24 heures
la preuve la photo de satellites de la
météo nationale prise aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il ya une erreur sur la photo
satellite d'hier ça mes enfants mais
c'est pas grave c'est à peu près le même
type de temps à savoir des orages sur le
sud-est du pays ailleurs c'est noir donc
pas de nuages donc c'est du beau temps
c'était celle d'hier m'enfin celle
d'aujourd'hui c'était quasiment la même
pardon pour ces petites erreurs pour le
nord-est du pays à la méditerranée le
temps sera passagèrement nuageux avec
quelques orages mais deezer à la sécurié
y des orages sans pluie il ya eu des
buts orages avec plus aujourd'hui et
beaucoup de rage sans pluie ont rappelé
à des orages de chaleur donc du nord est
la méditerranée partout ailleurs et bien
c'est du beau temps avec quelques petits
passages nuageux par ci par là plus ou
moins épais mais c'est du beau temps
dans l'ensemble les températures pour
demain minimum 21 degrés à cherbourg au
maximum 35 degrés en corse à ajaccio et
bastia et calvi et corte partout
ailleurs ça se situant autour de 26
degrés des températures estivales d'été
normales de saison
et demain c'est le lundi 19 juillet deux
minutes de soleil en moins levé 6h09
coucher 21h44 et puces et la
saint-arsène aussi voilà un bref rappel
des titres de la journée deux cent mille
manifestants en israël derrière menahem
begin qui a donné un mois à l'ol paie
pour quitter beyrouth et qui propose une
confédération entre israël et la
jordanie en automobile la victoire de
niki lauda au grand prix de brands hatch
en en bretagne et didier pironi deuxième
a pris la tête du championnat du monde
des conducteurs
enfin en cyclisme il n'aura encore
remporter l'étape contre-la-montre à
martigues ses suivants sont tout à fait
lâcher au classement général c'est
patricia charnolé qui à 23h15 va vous
développer l'ensemble de ces
informations
à 12h45 vous retrouverez philippe labro
demain et jean le plaisir quand à moi de
vous retrouver également à 20h appel à
notre réalisateur que nous sommes
aujourd'hui le dimanche 18 juillet
bonsoir à tous
à